maurice papon placé sous contrôle
judiciaire jusqu'à son procès le 8
octobre à bordeaux
les autorités veulent empêcher une
éventuelle fuite à l'étranger
la flambée du dollar 9 % pour le seul
mois de juillet conséquence entre autres
une hausse probable de l'essence dans
les tout prochains jours
grandes manoeuvres dans l'informatique
bill gates le patron de microsoft
investit 150 millions $ dans le capital
d'apple aux championnats du monde
d'athlétisme marie josé pérec eux
blessés déclarent forfait avant la
demi-finale du 200 m mais une autre
française sylviane felix s'est elle
qualifiée pour la finale
madame monsieur bonsoir les autorités de
la petite île britanniques de montserrat
tu envisages l'évacuation de tous les
habitants vers la guadeloupe voisine et
cela en raison de la menace que fait
peser l'éruption continue d'un volcan la
capitale qui a été évacuée déjà en avril
96 est d'ores et déjà pratiquement rayé
de la carte commentaires patrice
romedenne on appelle cela des coulées
pyroclastiques des avalanches de
poussière et de roches incandescente
dont certaines atteignent la taille
d'une voiture le tout déboule à 200
km/heure et submergent la ville de
plymouth à 4000 mètres en contrebas déjà
vidé de ses habitants en avril dernier
après que le volcan ce fut une première
fois réveillé plymouth est désormais
rayés de la carte
mais cette fois la colère de la
soufrière est telle qu'elles menacent
l'ensemble des habitants de montserrat
zone d'exclusion humaine ceux qui
avaient trouvé refuge dans le nord de
l'île doivent déguerpir le relief ne les
protège plus les retombées de cendre
rendent l'air irrespirable
l'eau est polluée le plan d'évacuation
actuellement en cours devrait mener les
5000 personnes pour ferrer vers les îles
voisines dont la guadeloupe qui
s'apprête à héberger deux mille réfugiés
ils laissent derrière eux une ville
fantôme
un caillou calciné leur pays
situation toujours plutôt tendue dans
l'archipel des comores ou deux ils le
demandent le rattachement à la france un
référendum devrait être organisé d'ici
la fin de l'année et le a envoyé une
mission de médiation
les autorités de moroni ont envoyé
aujourd'hui des émissaires sur place
mais les dirigeants séparatistes ont
refusé de les recevoir sur l'état
d'esprit de ces jeunes séparatistes
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux à
anjouan olivier car of bunny mériaux
sans eux le mouvement sécessionniste
dans je ne serais sans doute qu'un
épisode de plus dans la bataille pour le
pouvoir entre les responsables
politiques de la république comorienne à
mutsamudu les jeunes occupent
régulièrement les rues ici ils
représentent 60% de la population
l'énorme majorité n'a jamais eu de
travail
il m'a dit proprement parler bas et les
moches parce que j'ai terminé mes idées
n'était-il depuis 93 des chiots fromage
j'ai fait des études de quoi j'ai
terminé des études de droit
nous passons de nos travaux nous avons
là la magie trop jeunes ils n'ont jamais
connu la colonisation pour la plupart
ils veulent leur attachement à la france
et rien d'autre bruno caron 40 45 ans
qui avons disant lutter pour avoir cette
indépendance
je ne pense pas que nous souhaiterions
revenir en arrière de toute façon même
les français
le ministres des 190 l'a bien dit c'est
inconcevable un pays indépendant qui
revient sans cesse
on peut avoir une bonne coopération
franche c'est comme l'a toujours c'était
parce que la france est un pays m les
histoires sont pas les jeunes ne peut
pas comprendre parce que ce qu'ils ont
ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont besoin de
vivre ahmed fouad comme la plupart des
inconnus qui les enjoint soutien quand
même les chefs sécessionniste mais ils
l'avouent ils ne sait pas exactement où
le mouvement ni ou l'intransigeance des
jeunes d'anjou ans vont mener cette île
maurice papon placé sous contrôle
judiciaire jusqu'à son procès ainsi on a
décidé aujourd'hui la cour d'appel de
bordeaux
maurice papon qui sera jugé à partir de
8 octobre pour crimes contre l'humanité
va devoir entre autres remettre son
passeport aux autorités sur place
françois privat
pour maurice papon le placement sous
contrôle judiciaire ordonnée par la
chambre d'accusation de la cour d'appel
de bordeaux se traduit par une
interdiction de quitter le territoire
français
l'ancien secrétaire général de la
préfecture de la gironde sous le régime
de vichy doit remettre à la justice les
documents d'identité et l'informé de
tous ses déplacements en dehors de paris
c'est une décision importante parce que
il va de soi qu'il aurait été d'une
lourde responsabilité pour toute la
justice française
si le refus de prise de précautions
avaient facilité une éventuelle fuite de
maurice papon même si celui-ci s'en
défend rares étaient les parties civiles
présentes cet après midi au palais de
justice de bordeaux
pour elle cette mesure de contrôle
judiciaire est une garantie
supplémentaire un bon déroulement du
procès satisfaits
libérés d'un poids car nous sommes à
deux mois et demi du du procès il ne
faut pas que ne sait pas quand se dérobe
la justice est la seule solution était
d'envisager ce qui a été fait
aujourd'hui décidé aujourd'hui risque
pour sa vie parce qu'on a vu ce qui est
arrivé à monsieur bousquet alors on sait
jamais on n'est pas à la merci d'un faut
nous prendre notre vie pour nous on
préfère qu'ils nient d'armes entre
juillet 42 et 44 maurice papon est
accusé d'avoir joué un rôle actif dans
la déportation de 1560 juifs dont de
nombreux enfants il aurait facilité leur
transfert du camp de mérignac près de
bordeaux vers celui de drancy en
banlieue parisienne
ultime étape avant les camps
d'extermination nazis maurice papon ne
crois pas qu'il est présumé innocent il
est convaincu lui qu'il est présumé
coupable
j'avais espéré que les juges le
contredirait il ne l'a pas contredit
jean marc varaut a l'intention de former
un pourvoi en cassation de principe
contre le placement de maurice papon
sous contrôle judiciaire
un pourvoi qui a peu de chance d'être
examiné avant le début du procès le 8
octobre prochain
à noter également la décision du conseil
d'état qui a confirmé la suspension des
arrêtés pris par un certain nombre de
maires interdisant la circulation des
enfants la nuit dans leur ville
suspension provisoire en attendant un
débat juridique de fond sur cette
épineuse question quand le dollar flambe
l'essence explosent ou tout au moins à
son prix suite à la hausse continue du
billet vert comme on dit puce 22% depuis
le mois de janvier puisque 9 % pour le
seul mois de juillet les automobilistes
vont payer plus cher leur essence de 10
centimes en moyenne par litre
cette flambée du dollar pénalise
également un certain nombre de touristes
au portage fille visseyrias jean
françois ohlmann plus 10 centimes à la
pompe en moyenne c'est la surprise du
mois d'août tous les pétroliers français
ont augmenté leurs prix depuis le début
de la semaine
la raison en est simple les cours du
pétrole sont établis en dollars et le
dollar augmente l'essence coûte donc
plus cher sur les marchés internationaux
30 % de plus qu'il ya un mois un
ajustement qui ne plaît pas à tous les
automobilistes de la naissance diminue
pas pour autant alors c'est pas tout à
fait normal dopée par les performances
de l'économie américaine et par la perte
d'influencé du deutsche mark
le dollar a atteint son plus haut niveau
depuis octobre 1989 une hausse très
sensible depuis le début de cette année
de 5 francs 20 en janvier 1997 à 6
francs 36 ces derniers jours mais le
carburant n'est pas le seul secteur
affecté par la hausse du dollar
le tourisme en pâtit également chaque
année près d'un million de français
partent en vacances aux etats unis
aujourd'hui à washington devant la
maison blanche
les touristes français compter leurs
sous sur les sorties on va revoir parce
modéré mais au niveau des hôtels on a à
peu près se modérer je vais passer le
budget alors je suis obligé de puiser
sur le compte à paris les agences de
voyages ont déjà répercuté la hausse du
dollar sur leurs tarifs dans cette
agence les séjours ont augmenté de 16%
pour toutes les destinations en dehors
de l'europe que nous sommes nous-mêmes
facturées en dollars par le fournisseur
est que lorsque la facture du
fournisseur arrive un dollar que nous
payons 5 francs 20 au début de l'année
aujourd'hui nous payons 630 et nous
n'avons pas le choix que de réajuster
sauf a enregistré une perte
substantielle sur le dossier même si le
billet vert a augmenté de plus d'un
franc quelques mois de vacanciers ont
renoncé à leur voyage
il est vrai que nous sommes loin du
seuil des 10 francs pour un dollar
atteint et même dépassé au milieu des
années 80
le malheur des uns faisant le bonheur
des autres de nombreuses entreprises
exportatrices eux se félicite au
contraire de la hausse du billet vert
une vente à 10 $ qui rapportait 50
francs il ya encore quelques semaines
on rapporte désormais 60 une marge
inespéré pour certaines entreprises
exemple avec ce reportage de laurent
bailly et landrier fou
nous ne sommes pas dans une galerie de
jeux vidéo mais bien au siège de la très
dynamique société multimédia
ubisoft en banlieue parisienne avec ses
500 salariés et un chiffre d'affaires de
350 millions de francs dont la moitié à
l'export
l'entreprise tient la route ubisoft une
petite française qui fabrique des cd
roms de jeux vidéo et qui ose rivaliser
avec les géants américains et japonais
dans 41 pays
l'exportation c'est la clé de son succès
témoin ce jeu vidéo devenue emblématique
de la firme
vous avez la version suédoise la version
taille la version coréenne et c'est un
produit que nous avons vendu dans plus
de 40 pays pour voir que l'export c'est
une priorité pour ubisoft et enfle à la
hausse du dollar
extrêmement importante pour nous puisque
ça va nous permettre d'accroître nos
bijoux et le deuxième effet qui est à
plus long terme c'est que ça nous permet
d'investir beaucoup plus en qualité de
produits et en présence sur les marchés
étrangers
ce qui fait que par rapport aux
consommateurs en acquiert une présence
beaucoup plus durables parce que les
consommateurs réagissent énormément la
qualité des logiciels que l'on développe
développer c'est la priorité absolue
dans cet univers multimédia où tout va
très vite ou au bout d'un an une
génération de jeux et déjà périmé
pour rester à la page
il faut donc sans cesse investir et
grâce à la hausse du dollar
ubisoft est aujourd'hui en mesure de le
faire au delà de ses espérances
alors ici c'est l'euphorie et où vous
croyez vous que ce cédérom conçu pour
apprendre la guitare va être mise en
vente dès le mois prochain aux états
unis
bien sûr
quand bill gates croque la pomme cela
fait du bruit dans le landerneau et pas
seulement en bretagne le patron de
microsoft a annoncé son intention
d'investir quelque 150 millions de
dollars dans le capital de son ex ennemi
irréductible
apple computer précision frédéric rota
il ya plus de 20 ans cet homme
révolutionner l'informatique en mettant
sur le marché le premier ordinateur
individuel
grandeur et décadence steve jobs le
fondateur d'apple la marque à la pomme
croquée est obligé aujourd'hui de
s'incliner
il faut nous débarrasser de cette idée
selon laquelle pour qu'apple gagne
microsoft doit perdre
microsoft n'avait à vrai dire aucune
intention de perdre
microsoft c'est cet empire créé par le
désormais célèbre bill gates qui est
aujourd'hui l'homme le plus riche des
états unis et l'un des plus puissants du
monde
cette formidable réussite est le fruit
d'une véritable guerre dont apple sort
extrêmement affaibli 40% du personnel
avaient dû quitter la société apple a
toujours reproché à microsoft de lui
avoir emprunté pour ne pas dire plus
certaines de ces technologies
lancé il y a deux ans windows 95 marque
la consécration 2000 gates avec des
résultats d'une insolence rares 85 % du
marché mondial à microsoft 4 % pour
apple
l'accord officialisé hier prévoit que
microsoft injecte 150 millions de
dollars sous forme d'achat d'actions et
que les deux sociétés travaillent main
dans la main
intervenant en direct au congrès mondial
eeple de boston bill gates s'est voulu
rassurant seulement voilà apple n'a
toujours pas de pdg et se trouvent
financièrement dans le rouge
et puis surtout personne aujourd'hui ne
peut mesurer l'appétit réel de bill
gates qui réussit là le moins que l'on
puisse dire
une belle opération si l'action est
peule a fait un bond de 33% après
l'annnonce de cet accord et que
microsoft
cette décision ne fait pas que des
heureux pour certains passionnés
d'informatique cette alliance est
impensable
ce serait un peu le mariage du bon avec
le méchant reportage patrice pollet
françois granier en france ils ne sont
que 10 % utiliser le système macintosh
d'apple
une poignée dont face aux 90% de ceux
qui ont choisi l'autre système
celui de bill gates l'association
microsoft windows
les deux formules cohabitaient mal une
lutte technique qui posait bien des
problèmes au moment de l'achat chaque
système ayant ses qualités et ses
défauts
pour apple les macs on disait simplicité
très bonne fabrication mais une
utilisation à plus rude pour le pc
microsoft rapidité énormes possibilités
d'emploi de logiciels mais fiabilité
fluctuante mais je crois que le système
d'exploitation qui ont échappé il ya
quelques années
en termes d'ergonomie et convivialité
beaucoup davantage sur sur le pc mais
qu'aujourd'hui les nouvelles versions de
windows notamment windows 95 ont
rattrapé leur retard et que
pour un utilisateur comme moi amateurs
il n'y a plus de difficultés à utiliser
aujourd'hui un pc et wii au fil du temps
les deux formules s'était améliorée pour
presque se rejoindre grâce à l'accord
entre les deux sociétés
les systèmes seront compatibles qu'apple
va pouvoir continuer à développer ses
machines que les logiciels microsoft que
même vont être portés systématiquement
sur les machines d'apple donc d'avenir
est beaucoup plus rose qu'ils ne
l'étaient il ya quelques mois face au
géant microsoft apple reste dans la
course aux ulis les responsables de la
marque en france semblent satisfaits de
l'accord passé
nous restons deux sociétés indépendantes
nous avons juste resserrer nos liens de
partenariat mais les deux marques
continueront à exister sur le marché
séparément et à proposer l'une et
l'autre une gamme de produits tout à
fait intéressante désormais plus
d'angoise aux moments délicats d'acheter
votre ordinateur
seul le prix déterminera votre choix
c'est dit-on la loi des séries des états
unis on était tous yeux aujourd'hui par
une nouvelle catastrophe aérienne un
avion cargo s'est écrasé à
l'atterrissage à proximité de l'aéroport
de miami
pascal doucet bon l'avion avec ses
quatre membres d'équipage s'est écrasé
au beau milieu d'une zone industrielle
et commerciale à l'ouest de l'aéroport
international
à l'heure de la sortie des bureaux il a
d'abord touché le sol au milieu d'un
champ puis il a traversé l'autoroute et
a fini sa course dans la banque qui est
au coin et là plusieurs voitures ont
explosé
l'appareil est un dc 8 cargo de la
compagnie find her spécialisée dans le
transport de fret entre l'amérique du
sud et les états unis
il venait de décoller et on a pour
l'instant aucune idée des causes du
crash dans les deux bâtiments touchés
qui était une banque et un hangar
plusieurs personnes finissent elles en
journée de travail les débris que vous
voyez ici s'étale sur près d'un
kilomètre
pour l'instant les pompiers et
l'administration fédérale de l'aviation
civile ne donne aucun bilan
quant à la catastrophe de l'île de guam
selon le tout dernier bilan
225 passagers et membres d'équipage du
boeing coréens ont trouvé la mort dans
cet accident
on recense une trentaine de survivants
la plupart dans un état critique
jacques cardoze miraculé et première
évacuer des 27 survivants de l'accident
de la korean air lines et camatte soudas
le gouverneur de l'île américaine a tenu
à la délivrer de son calvaire
personnellement cette jeune japonaise
confie avoir vu sa mère brûlé dans le
fuselage avant de ramper pour se dégager
des débris métalliques le vol 801 27
survivants 2 127 morts et des familles
de victimes
plongez dans l'affliction et la colère
à bout de nerfs il accuse la compagnie
coréenne
elle ne les aurait pas suffisamment
assister après le drame une compagnie
qui exige un droit de regard sur l'
enquête et l'examen des boîtes noires
présenté aujourd'hui à la presse à
washington
je pense qu'il y a dix sept paramètres
17 choses à prendre en compte comme le
vent la vitesse où l'altitude
nous avons réalisé une première lecture
des bandes elles sont toutes les deux de
bonne qualité l'enquète n'en dira pas
plus on sait seulement que l'appareil
effectué une descente normale avant le
choc sans préciser si une erreur humaine
ou une défaillance mécanique est à
l'origine de l'accident
les championnats du monde d'athlétisme
atteignent française va participer à la
finale du 200 m mais pas celle que l'on
attendait sylviane félix déjà championne
du monde junior c'est en effet
brillamment qualifiés tout à l'heure
alors que marie josé pérec déclaré
forfait pour raisons médicales
récit de notre envoyé spécial laurent
frédéric bollée 18h37 après midi à
athènes à l'heure de l'ultime coup de
théâtre de marie josé pérec
la championne olympique vient de se
blesser elle ne participera pas à sa
demi-finale du 200 m
dans le virage avec un voile
en plus c'était la dernière course que
je faisais
ouais
le point qui fait mal se trouve à la
cuisse droite voix faible visage triste
marie jo ne tiendra pas son rang lors de
ces championnats du monde comme s'il
était maintenant pourrait qu'elle avait
raison de ne pas vouloir venir
marie-jo s'éloigne tête basse le verdict
médical est sans appel elle a une lésion
musculaire authentique c'est à dire le
type de déchirer qu'on avait des
élongations celle avec petite déchirure
qui imposent le recours immédiat c'est
sûr qui ne permet pas de continuer à
courir faire quelques activités de
l'athlétisme peu ce soir et qui ensuite
demande quelques semaines de préparation
le couloir 6 reste donc ville au moment
du départ c'est un coup dur pour
l'équipe de france c'est vraiment
regrettable parce que c'est pour nous
c'est quand même j'ai toujours dit c'est
un chef de file c'est une méga you seek
inutiles qui va nous échapper
alors s'il fallait se consoler et dit on
dirait que perec s'en va et félix
arrive-t-il de félix aura au départ de
la finale demain la maintenance que le
final
je vais essayer d'être dans maison et
puis si si le bonheur doit s'accomplir
et accomplira marie-jo indisponible
plusieurs semaines si dieu me fais dit
ce qui se révèle après tout qui sait si
l'on n'a pas échangé aujourd'hui à
athènes il faire de l'athlétisme
français centre une route des
championnats du monde à nouveau
éclaboussés par des affaires de dopage
contrôlé positif l'ukrainien alexandre
bagages a été dépossédée de sa médaille
d'or du lancer du poids
le français pascal le maran inscrits
dans le 400 m e v a lui aussi été exclu
de ces championnats du monde
la crise au proche orient il ya c'est
rafa tu as tenté de rassurer les
américains en s'engageant à promouvoir
davantage la sécurité en israël tout en
mettant en garde je cite contre une
gigantesque explosion si israël ne lève
pas les mesures anti palestiniennes
prises depuis l'attentât de jérusalem
qui a fait je vous le rappelle 13 morts
le 30 juillet parmi les victimes de cet
attentat quelques palestiniens ce qui
provoque des difficultés inextricables
parmi les familles séparées reportage
charles enderlin
13h20 le 30 juillet dernier parmi les
nombreuses victimes de l'attentât un
adolescent inconnu et transporté à
l'hôpital
gravement blessé il vient de perdre une
jambe et souffre de brûlures profondes
et dans le coma à jérusalem-est la
famille de sai trader s'inquiète ce
jeune palestinien qui travaille chez un
maraîcher amara n'ayez houda ne rentre
pas
le père abdul rahman est bloquée au
barrage israélien sa carte d'identité
orange de cisjordanie lui interdit le
passage sans autorisation spéciale
nadja la mer à elle une identité bleue
d'habitantes de jérusalem et peut donc
se déplacer
elle croit que son fils a été arrêté et
tente en vain d'obtenir des informations
au commissariat de police
ce n'est que le lendemain que les radars
apprendront que ça aide est en salle de
réanimation à l'hôpital hadassah
abderrahmane n'est autorisée à se rendre
au chevet de son fils que 48 heures plus
tard il obtient l'autorisation de
séjourner à jérusalem pendant trois
jours et seulement jusqu'à 19
m
raed le frère aîné qui peut lui passer
la journée à l'hôpital à de bonnes
nouvelles
saeed a repris connaissance il va mieux
et se souvient de ce qui lui est arrivé
il dit que c'est un crime
le lendemain nadj là la mère vient au
chevet du blessé
un tel attentat est inhumain c'est un
crime contre les arabes contre les juifs
contre des innocents les assurances
israéliennes devraient couvrir les frais
d'hospitalisation mais personne n'est
encore venu à l'aide de cette famille
abdul rahman gagne 2000 francs par mois
et ça aide travailler au marché pour
l'aider comme leurs parents quatre des
huit enfants sont enregistrés en israël
les autres en territoire palestinien est
théoriquement ils ne peuvent pas se
rencontrer ce soir à mâcon trois
importants éleveurs engraisseurs de
bovins de la région du charolais ont été
mises en examen dans une affaire de
trafic et d' usage d'hormones l'un d'eux
chez qui les enquêteurs ont découvert
des produits les anabolisants a été
incarcéré les deux autres ont été placés
sous contrôle judiciaire avec
interdiction d'exercer
la prochaine visite de jean paul ii en
france provoque quelques remous
le vatican en effet confirmé l'intention
du pape de se rendre sur latence du
professeur jérôme lejeune décédé il ya
maintenant trois ans et qui était un
conseiller très écouté du pape en
matière de morale
ce catholique convaincu qu'ils avaient
réussi à isoler le chromosome
responsable du mont gaullisme avait
ensuite mené le combat contre
l'avortement à la tête de l'association
laissez les vivre autre remous autour de
cette visite papale l'information lancée
par le canard enchaîné selon laquelle
d'anciens mercenaires ont été recrutés
pour assurer la sécurité de certains
sites des journées mondiales de la
jeunesse en quête marque maisonneuve
jean françois rude où pendant 24 350
mille personnes au moins seront
installés là si pendant la messe le
calme est de rigueur il y à d'autres
moments
et là qui va surveiller garder les kids
elle selon le canard enchaîné des
anciens du 11e choc seront chargés de la
surveillance des brebis égarées un
régiment où il y aurait plus de
mercenaires que d'enfants de choeur la
ligne de défense du coordinateur
interministériel est ce un saut du lit
en pensant j'enchaîné 11e choc que je
connais bien qui
ne sont pas deux au front et les affreux
dont parle le canard enchaîné je le
connais pas personnellement du tout donc
le les affreux c'est le nom que les
anciens du 11e choc se donne entre
certains auraient un lourd passé
judiciaire mais au sein de
l'organisation de la visite du pape on
ne veut pas la mort du pécheur
je ne suis pas la plus il ya une
entreprise qui est frauduleuse il faut
que la police ou la justice en au cube
l'association bagheera composé des
anciens du 11e choc a quitté sans
laisser d'adressé
son dernier domicile connu à saint tôt
en revanche une société portant le même
nom bagheera existe dans le 8e
arrondissement de paris elle s'occupera
de la sécurité de longchamp mais selon
son principal dirigeant
aucun de ses membres n'a de démêlés avec
la justice à longchamp pendant les
préparatifs ce qui inquiète pour
l'instant ce n'est pas tant l'arrivée
des supposés mercenaires le 24 août que
la venue de la pluie
plusieurs centaines d'arlésiens ont
rendu ce matin tout dernier hommage à
jeanne calment qui a été inhumé hier
dans la plus stricte intimité
la messe a été célébrée dans la
primatiale saint trophime une église où
jeanne calment avait l'habitude de venir
se recueillir chaque soir et cela
jusqu'à l'âge de 108 ans
cette période des vacances scolaires est
l'occasion d'un certain nombre
d'initiatives propre à favoriser une
meilleure compréhension entre européens
c'est ainsi qu'un certain nombre de
jeunes sont hébergés bénévolement dans
un petit village près de lyon à charge
pour eux de participer tout aussi
bénévolement à certains travaux
reportage vincent guyenne olivier robert
avec son étrange panneaux cet homme qui
a recompté la guerre ce jour là ne
pouvait éveiller notre curiosité
alors avant vous attendent et qui alors
ne manque encore une garce ans qui vient
de nettoyer lui même et polonais ses
camarades sont turcs français ou tchèque
le sac sur le dos ils partent en
vacances leur destination
moi non mornant 4500 habitants
son clocher son célèbre aqueduc romain
son lac et son mur à reconstruire un mur
de pierres sèches sur lequel ce groupe
de jeunes va passé toutes ses vacances
sous l'oeil expérimenté d'un maçon
retraité ne parle que le français est
par trop bien mais il ya des jeunes qui
parle français anglais et se
débrouillent donne les ordres
les autres sont bien répercutées une
main d'oeuvre de qualité donc qui plus
est bénévole casser des cailloux pour
les vacances drôle d'idée
pas tant que ça on s'est rencontré il ya
à peine quelques jours et on se sent
déjà comme une famille c'est bon de
travailler ensemble et puis c'est que le
matin le travail n'est qu'un prétexte
pour l'association jeunesse et
reconstruction
il s'agit d'abord de favoriser les
échanges entre jeunes du monde entier
pour moi ce que vous faites
j'apprends maintenant j'apprends pagnol
j'ai commencé il y à 50 ans et l'après
guerre c'était surtout pour la pour la
mort c'est la reconstruction du pays en
fait et c'est essentiellement des
chantiers plus ou moins binationaux pour
en plus amorcer la réconciliation franco
allemande
et puis après c'est vrai qu'on a
vraiment développé les changes
internationales entre jeunes
pour participer à ce chantier ils ont
payé une cotisation aux 700 francs
environ
la nourriture est fourni mais il faut
savoir cuisiner quant aux logements
prêté par la mairie
il est un peu spartiate à l'image du
village la soirée sera fort calme
qu'importe bang inra qu'elle et les
autres ont des mains et de choses à se
raconter avec les autochtones ils ont
finalement peu de contacts malgré la
bonne volonté de certains sur quelques
plages françaises certains privilégiés
ont réellement vue sur la mer
c'est le cas notamment à sangatte dans
le pas de calais en compagnie de
marianne masse et de 2000 mah ce
reportage sur une curieuse tradition
immobilière 9 heures sur la digue de
sangatte
une brise chaude vient réveiller les
chalets le paysage ressemblerait presque
à la californie idéal pour le jogging
des aficionados on dirait que pour les
futures bulles sont toujours connu ça
puis alors les gens au fur et à mesure
ils ont amélioré qui n'est pas un as qui
habite carrément le pendant deux mois un
chemin sur un kilomètre et demi de
digues 149 chalet moins ceux qui ont
disparu dans les tornades ou qui ont
brûlé leur histoire remonte aux années
60 construit par des gens du cru
amoureux de la mer vous avez la
particularité d'avoir un blockhaus vous
dans votre jardin se lire comme on l'a
vu bâtir on était pendant la guerre 40
alors là il est reconvertie en waters le
confort rudimentaire pour certains et un
peu moins pour d'autres un seul compteur
d'eau pour tout le monde
quant à l'électricité on se débrouille
avec des batteries ou des lampes à gaz
parce qu'ici l'essentiel est ailleurs
on sait les petits déjeuners c'est la
nuit quand on dort on entend le roulis
de la mer la mer qui monte la mer qui
redescend les bateaux que l'on voit
l'hovercraft qui passe très près quand
il ya des grands vents la pêche aux
moules la pêche aux crevettes les balmer
la tranquillité et l'espace mais les
chalets joue aussi un rôle important
dans la protection du site côté face ils
ont la mer côté pile la campagne entre
deux ils permettent de faire rempart
contre les mares
et c'est même inscrit dans le cahier des
charges nous sommes tenus d'entretenir
la dune même de replanter ce que vous
par exemple la les oyats était mort
d'avoir planté un petit peu sans la
présence de chalets au piétinement de la
foule mettrait à mal cette dune et
finalement la fera disparaître en
quelques années
plus étonnant le caractère temporaire
des habitations qui ne peuvent être
vendus à chaque renouvellement de bail
la rumeur court que les chalets vont
disparaître mais ils tiennent bon leurs
occupants ne sont pas prêts à renoncer
au coucher de soleil sur l'angleterre
l'eau l'air la vie quoi pendant que
leurs petits frères font les
intéressants au club mickey quelques 140
jeunes musiciens venus de toute l'europe
ont choisi eux pour leurs vacances de
s'enfermer à la cité de la musique à la
villette à paris
cet orchestre d'un été parrainés et
dirigé par les plus grands chefs
d'orchestre parmi lesquels pierre boulez
au portage de nos spécialistes des
jeunesses musicales louis carzou dida
comme dans tout les colos il y en a qui
sont en retard mais c'est bien là le
seul point commun
karl orchestre des jeunes n'a rien d'un
club de vacances une sélection
impitoyable 6 heures de répétition par
jour sans oublier les concerts et le
pire c'est qu'ils en redemandent
on n'a pas vraiment le temps de visiter
la ville
mais c'est bien rencontrer les autres
musiciens et puis de jouer tous ensemble
de nouveaux fondée il ya dix ans pour
permettre aux jeunes musiciens de l'est
de jouer à londres ou paris
l'institution recrute désormais dans 20
pays
le niveau musical lui est resté à la
hauteur des chefs d'orchestre tels que
pierre boulez buts moi je considère que
les jeunes professionnels il faut les
traiter comme des professionnels et par
des jeunes dire bien sûr qu'ils
présentent des manques
c'est dire qu'ils n'ont pas encore une
expérience accumulée mais très souvent
dans tout ça ce qu'on pense parce qu'ils
sont très attentifs sur elle même
vous êtes au fond comme une rambarde il
ya quelques fois dans des chemins assez
le long des précipices devait des
petites rambarde si vous vous appuyez
dessus ça cracra et vous tomberez bon
alors ce qui met ses rations pour la vue
mais à un moment donné le sceptre que
c'est ça c'est la rambarde ne vous
aiment pas ils n'ont pas besoin de
s'appuyer sur lui mais c'est sécurisant
tout simplement
après paris lors qu'est ce que s'apprête
à partir en tournée
six festivals à travers l'europe et les
tournées il n'y a rien de tel pour
former la jeunesse la musiciens
pour nos bambins la perspective de
visiter un château peut s'avérer
quelquefois un peu rébarbative ce n'est
pas le cas à la roche guyon où les
jeunes visiteurs sont appelés à jouer en
quelque sorte les apprentis détectives
reportage sophie nenni chaque gérard
nous cet après midi quelle va être notre
mission de retrouver la lettre et bien
voilà l'achat retrouver la lettre dans
le château et elles cherchent ils à
lettres cachées par le célèbre
professeur mortimer c'est le défi relevé
par ses enfants
transformée le temps d'un après-midi en
apprentis détectives tout au long de
leur parcours parsemé d'énigmes et
d'embûches il découvre l'univers étrange
de l'auteur de bande dessinée est garp
et j'accorde et apprennent en jonc
l'histoire du château de la roche-guyon
décor de la 6ème aventures de blake et
mortimer rosé d'anjou alors aidé d'une
animatrice
ils vont poursuivre leur enquête dans
les dédales du château du donjon au 15
mars
m
majeur la mare à goutte de produit du
lait caillé au poivre vert le message
secret que vous avez découvert dans
cette recette c'est descendre jusqu'aux
casemate en traversant les chapelles la
surprise du piège diabolique cette
machine à remonter le temps que les
enfants découvrent au terme des épreuves
exténués mais ravi les enfants ont
réussi leur pari prudence tout de même
des visiteurs se serait perdu dans le
temps ce pour toujours avec un retour
aux championnats du monde d'athlétisme
d'athènes avec l'une des épreuves les
plus attendues
le 110 métro et qui vient de se dérouler
il ya quelques minutes
tout de suite le commentaire de travail
sur place laurent frédéric bollée n
philibert brillamment qualifiées à
l'issue des demi finales va-t-il nous
refaire le coup de téva diagana ce sera
dur mais néanmoins pourquoi pas donc une
bonne surprise à part de dan philibert
au couloir je vous le rappelle numéro 6
le premier départ est le bon delphi
libère ne semble parti un peu lentement
en tout cas évidemment on attendait la
lutte au sommet entre le comme jack
johnson ces cas allen johnson qui semble
devant largement aller johnson america
qui va empêcher ces championnats du
monde sylvain enfin peut-être qu'on sait
malheureusement c'est mme philibert à
mon avis et 5e alors que l'allemand
choir coptes et je sais sur la une pour
hacher semble aussi de la médaille de
bronze en tout cas victoire de
l'américain allen johnson en 12 93 à 2
centièmes seulement du record du monde
c'est la meilleure performance mondiale
de l'année
on n'est pas passé loin d'un grand
exploit et du premier record du monde de
ces championnats du monde d'athènes
en tout cas selon
dell philibert a terminé 5e peut-être
quatrième je ne sais pas sur eure la
confirmation du classement ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'il n'y aura pas de médaille
française ce soir
décidément le sort s'acharne sur
l'équipage de la station orbitale mir
confond aujourd'hui à de nouveaux
problèmes d'alimentation en oxygène
quelques heures seulement avant
l'arrivée de l'équipe de relève
le soyouz transportant les dépanneurs de
l'espace est arrivé s'est arrimé tout à
l'heure à la station mir en fin d'après
midi nous allons voir les images le saas
vient d'être ouvert et les cinq
cosmonautes se sont retrouvés il ya
quelques minutes tout de suite de
commentaires en direct de patrice plais
bien oui nous sommes en direct de la
station mir je vous précise qu'elle est
à la verticale donc de baïkonour les
antennes de réception sont juste à la
verticale
la station mir qui tourne donc à 400 km
le panneau que vous voyez c'est le
panneau donc le sas d'ouverture entre le
soyouz tm 6 à l'intérieur sont passés il
renvoie en ce moment l'ingénieur
vinogradov j'ai l'impression qui est en
train de sortir qui est toujours
soucieuse d m6 le commandant lui
anatolie solowiej est déjà sorti donc
c'est une bonne façon de commencer cette
mission arrimage réussi
la station mir va sans doute être
réparée grâce à cette arrivée réussi
demain j'ai écouté l'ensemble de
l'équipage avec l'américain que l'on
voit la main et avec quelle folle va
donc commencer la procédure de
réparation et on pourra je pense dans
quinze jours commencé à mettre les
combinaisons pour pénétrer dans le
module ce prêtre le module spectre à
l'intérieur on va donc rebrancher donc
les panneaux solaires les panneaux
solaires accidenté lors de la collision
du 25 juin avec un vaisseau un vaisseau
progress qui amenait du ravitaillement
et on va donc en profiter aussi pour
chercher le trou de 3 cm qui se trouve
donc dans la carlingue dans
l'infrastructure de cette station dans
cette partie de la station mir spectre
et puis au mois de septembre
eh bien on va donc sortir à l'extérieur
faire une sortie dans l'espace pour
cette fois-ci voir le trou mais à partir
de l'espace de façon à apprécier d'une
façon définitive ce qu'on va pouvoir
faire pour la station mir c'est à dire
essayer de la sauver la maintenir en vie
jusqu'à la construction de la plateforme
alpha et ça ça sera dans deux trois ans
seulement les premières les premiers
débuts de la construction de cette
station
voilà où vivait cet événement direct
nous y reviendrons bien sûr dans le
dernier journal à la st gaétan suspense
palpitant la scène se passe dans le ciel
australien cette fois deux parachutistes
effectuer des figures au dessus de
brisbane
lorsque les deux voiles se sont emmêlés
les deux parachutistes ont gardé leur
sang froid ils ont réussi à se dépêtrer
avant d'ouvrir leurs parachutes de vents
trop ils sont donc sains et saufs tous
les deux cette scène a été immortalisée
par un de leurs collègues qui lui non
plus n'a pas manqué de réflexes
voilà dernier journal sur france 2 vers
00h30 en compagnie de laurence ostolaza
dans un instant le point route de
valérie maurice la météo nathalie
rihouet les orages vont se calmer pas
nathalie demain à 13h vous retrouverez
antoine cormery et à 20h fille bluffé
très très bonne soirée
merci bonsoir